bonjour à tous aujourd'hui une courte
vidéo pour vous annoncer la sortie de
mon nouveau livre le deuxième en fait
qui s'appelle insoluble mais vrai voilà
donc qui sort chez flammarion le 31 m et
c'est un livre qui est consacrée aux
grands problèmes non résolus de la
science ce que les scientifiques
appellent souvent les problèmes ouverts
alors des problèmes non résolus en
sciences y en a pleins évidemment c'est
le travail des chercheurs tous les jours
mais parmi tous ces problèmes non
résolus en fait il y en a quelques-uns
qui jouissent un peu d'un statut
particulier soit parce que ils ont une
importance vraiment fondamental dans
leur domaine
soit parce que certains ont une
importance historique à certains de ses
problèmes non résolus qui sont là depuis
des décennies voire des siècles et qui
résiste toujours et il ya aussi certains
de ces problèmes qui sont
particulièrement fascinant parce qu'ils
ont l'air très simple en apparence et
pourtant ça peut faire effectivement des
décennies que les chercheurs se casse
les dents dessus alors fidèle à mon
habitude j'ai décidé en fait de parler
d'un peu tous les domaines de la science
donc je parle de physique notamment de
physique fondamentale par exemple qu'est
ce qui s'est passé avant le big bang
voilà problèmes non résolus je parle de
biologie par exemple pourquoi est-ce
qu'on dort bah oui aussi incroyable que
ça puisse paraître en fait on ne sait
pas vraiment comprends pas pourquoi on a
besoin de dormir je parle aussi de
mathématiques par exemple comment sont
réparties et les nombres premiers
et puis je parle de sujets qui pour
certains sont à ses fondamentaux
d'autres peuvent avoir des applications
technologiques ou médical assez
importante par exemple comment
fonctionne la supraconductivité
ou alors pourquoi est-ce qu'on vieillit
si on comprenait mieux pour convier
certainement on perd même certaines
autres attirent des progrès notamment en
médecine voila ca par les classiques
maths-physique bio j'aborde aussi un peu
de géologie un peu d'algorithmique aussi
un peu de linguistique voilà donc
j'essaye de traiter un peu tous les
domaines de la science alors deux
questions que l'on pose souvent au sujet
de livres comme ça premier set première
question c'est le niveau du livre alors
c'est à peu près le niveau on va dire de
ce que je peux faire en vidéo sur la
chaîne
c'est à dire que c'est pas un livre qui
est destiné à des jeunes enfants par
exemple
mais ce n'est pas non plus un livre qui
s'adresse à des gens qui auraient fait
d'études scientifiques poussées voilà
c'est un livre pour pour le grand public
qui s'intéresse à la culture
scientifique
l'autre question qu'on pose souvent
c'est le rapport avec ce que j'ai pu
faire en vidéo sur la chaîne alors
vraiment je vois ça comme deux choses
indépendante
c'est à dire que le livre est pas du
tout une reprise des scripts de ce que
j'aurais pu faire en vidéo un pas du
tout d'autant plus que moi à la base je
suis plutôt quelqu'un qui j'écrivais
avant de faire des vidéos moi je suis
plutôt quelqu'un qui vient de l'écrire
c'est pas du tout ça
al'inverse je ne suis pas censuré si
j'avais envie de traiter dans le livre
un sujet que j'avais déjà traité en
vidéo si vous n'avez pas envie de de
faire l'impasse sur un problème que je
trouvais très bon très important sous
prétexte que j'en avais déjà parlé en
vidéo
voilà un certain nombre des problèmes
qui font un lien avec des choses que
j'ai pu traiter en vidéo par exemple
voilà sur les nombres premiers ou sur de
la physique fondamentale
voilà je vois ça comme moi comme deux
choses voilà donc le livre sort chez
flammarion
il a été illustré par lisons bernet avec
qui j'avais déjà travaillé sur sur le
premier livre mais qui attrapait le
bison 2x donc lille on a fait des les
superbes illustrations sur sur chacun
des chapitres est donc le livre sort le
31 mai donc au moment où sort cette
vidéo normalement il est pas encore
sorti mais vous pouvez déjà le trouver
en précommande dans notamment les
grandes enseignes et les grands sites
internet si vous avez envie de le
précommander je vous incite à le faire
parce que du coup ça permet d'améliorer
le
lancement du livre et ça permet aussi
aux distributeurs de mieux
approvisionner les stocks donc voilà si
vous si vous souhaitez le précommander
fait le parce que voilà ça ahmed saeed
la visibilité du livre et sinon donc à
partir du 31 mai il sera disponible dans
toutes les bonnes librairies
n'hésitez pas à le demander à votre
mairie de quartier s'ils n'ont pas voilà
donc j'espère que le livre vous plaira
et puis d'ici là je vous dis à très
bientôt pour des nouvelles vidéos
non
oh
[Musique]